حسنًا ، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، كل ما تمت مناقشته
بين البلدين كان
مدعومًا أيضًا بالكثير من المشاورات والتحليل ،
وهذا ليس قرارًا تعسفيًا ،
فهؤلاء قادة
متطورون ينظرون أيضًا إلى ما يحدث
عالميًا ، وينظرون إلى ما يحدث على
مستوى الاقتصاد الكلي ، لذلك كان هذا قرارًا
قرار عالمي مدروس جيدًا
ومدعوم من قبل الوزراء وكادرنا
الفني وقد تشاورنا أيضًا
مع جميع زملائنا في
مسألة جيوسياسية ولكن
مهمة بالنسبة للمنطقة
تخسر إيران حوالي 50 مليار دولار
سنويًا من الصادرات بسبب العقوبات الأمريكية التي
فقدت حوالي 2  و 1/2 مليون
برميل يوميًا من الصادرات في العام الماضي ،
أليس هذا برميل بارود في
المنطقة يجب أن تتعامل معه ، بل هو
خطر شديد للغاية وضع جانباً
دوافع دونالد ترامب ، أعتقد أن لدينا
قضايا سياسية  الجاد مع
إيران زميلي وزير
الخارجية وزميلي وزير
الخارجية أو وزير الدولة للشؤون الخارجية
هما أكثر من  نحن مؤهلون للحديث
عنها وكيفية حلها وإيران
تعرف ما يجب عليها فعله للانضمام إلى
الدول المتحضرة وأن نكون أصدقاء مع
المملكة العربية السعودية ، لقد مدنا دائمًا
سلاحنا وسلامنا مع
إيران وإذا فعلت إيران الشيء الصحيح
سيجدوننا جارًا متقبلًا جدًا
لهم ، قال الوزير الإيراني إنه
لن يتفاوض على الحكومة
لن تذهب ، لقد أكلت مع هذه العقوبات الأمريكية
التي تضغط عليهم على النفط وهو
محفظتك التي لست مهتمًا بها على الإطلاق.
أي تأثير ستخلفه عقوبات النفط المفروضة على البصل
علينا أو على
الأسواق العالمية ، أشعر بالقلق على الرغم من أن
أمن إمدادات النفط من
التهديدات من الجهات الحكومية وغير الحكومية
التي رأيناها رأينا السفن تتعرض
للهجوم.
تعرضت خطوط الأنابيب للهجوم ،
رأينا إطلاق طائرات بدون طيار من
ميليشيات عملاء لإيران ،
وهذا يعرض إمدادات الطاقة العالمية
للخطر ، وقد عبرنا عن ذلك في
الاجتماع الوزاري لمجموعة العشرين وكان كاي
منذ ثلاثة أسابيع.  ولا يزال يمثل
خطرًا علينا اليوم ، لكننا سنفعل
كل ما هو ضروري للدفاع عن
أراضينا عن أصولنا أو ممراتنا الملاحية
والتأكد من أن
أمن الطاقة في العالم لم يأخذ
كرهينة من قبل أي نظام.